hi welcome to a digital defense my name
is jordan robertson i'm a cybersecurity
reporter here with Bloomberg and
Washington DC and this is our weekly
cybersecurity show so we want to talk
this week about what everybody's talking
about the election and you know we we in
the news media spent countless hours
dissecting the hacking attacks leading
up to the election and what we wanted to
look at today was well what actually
happened on Election Day and you know
are we going to find evidence of further
you know alleged Russian tampering in
the election as we move forward there's
a lot to unpack here so we're going to
dive right in a little bit of background
as everybody knows you know leading up
to the election the US government
accused Russian hackers working on
behalf of the Russian government for
hacking the the Democratic Party's
emails leaking emails on Hillary Clinton
and her campaign and the foundation and
you know as it's been described as an
information war and I think that's a
pretty fair assessment of where we as a
country found ourselves leading up to
november eighth this was an information
war which you know if the intelligence
community's assessment is to be believed
you know was was was perpetrated by
Russia this is something they're very
good at and one of the key takeaways I
want you to have from this week's show
is that you know this is not the end
it's not the end of that alleged
information war and one thing I wanted
to mention is that you know this being
our our internet show on cyber security
we want this to be very interactive so
if you have questions or comments you
know please post them and we will try to
address as many of them as possible here
on the show so please feel free to view
this as a conduit to ask many questions
comments you don't have that discussion
in real time so wanted to take you into
kind of what are you know battle plan
was on election night and some
interesting stuff we saw so like every
other news organization watching this
there was we run kind of high alert for
is there going to be a major attempt to
disrupt the actual voting on Election
Day and as everybody knows now in terms
of what we
seen so far the answer that is no and
there's a very interesting visual way to
show you what exactly we were looking at
on election night and why it was so
peculiar and unusual so what I'm going
to bring up here is a map showing what
what's called denial of service attacks
around the internet these are computer
to computer attacks designed to take out
internet connections so if you're going
to disrupt the election on election
night you would see lots and lots of
activity on a chart like this so here's
what you're looking at this is from an
organization it's called digital attack
map calm and now this is a collaboration
between Google and a company called
arbor networks so this is obviously a
very respected data set that we're
looking at here this is november eighth
this looks interesting you're seeing a
lot of attacks from Southeast Asia
Summit Latin America some the United
States you know what you're seeing here
is actually denial of service attacks
that are well below the usual normal
level of attacks and you know this this
chart will allow you to do you know
several things one of which is let me
show you what it looks like on a heavy
attack day so you go back to let's call
it call it August you see this is what's
called a heavy attack day you know you
can see lots and lots of traffic you
know from Asia to the us-brazil you know
you go back to november eighth you know
that's just one example you can see and
a lot of security companies confirm this
november eighth basically the internet
went silent and in from a security
perspective that's a good thing you're
not seeing a ton of attack traffic
you're not seeing state registrar's
websites going down you're not seeing
new sights go down in terms of the
information flow it was wide open on
election night that's very unusual this
map is actually very unusual because
what it basically indicates is that you
know a group or a collection of groups
basically said let's hang out tonight
let's put everything we're doing on
pause and let's let the information flow
now if you believe the intelligence
community's assessment about who was
behind the attacks on our election you
know that would
indicate that Russia you know I told its
subordinates let's hang out tonight
let's not do anything crazy let's let
this play out as its supposed to so
that's one takeaway from you know from
this map and I wanted to get to a couple
of questions we're getting in as well
first question to come in was you know
did the government take any specific
measures to stop the hackers good
question like a lot of news
organizations we we know we did a lot of
preparatory research going into election
night about you know what exactly is the
government doing to stop any potential
attack on election night and the
government had what's called msi sac
which is multi-state i sack information
sharing center where the states would
send information about cyber attacks if
they were to see them I got to tell you
we were very surprised what we called
the center and and their their
designated you know point person you
know throughout the night basically
nothing they didn't see you know they
saw very very little and the information
that we got back was very very few
reports of coordinated attacks on
election systems or information sharing
systems again that's very unusual so
like you know when you're seeing lots of
attacks that's unusual when you're
seeing no attacks that's also unusual
and both indicate intention so I can't
stress that point enough the fact that
we didn't see you know we saw hardly any
denial of service attacks you know of
Merit you know on this map and the fact
that the msi sac was reporting
essentially no large-scale intrusion
traffic that's really revealing that
indicates a coordination of efforts to
not attack you know and and the point I
want to make there was you know you can
kind of take off a list of what would
you expect on election night and there
are a few different things like you'd
see in this map you could expect a flood
of denial of service attacks you know I
geared toward news organizations you
know states that are reporting results
things like that knock them off line
makes it harder to get access to
information you know you would also
expect you know attacks against state
systems to be report to the government
they weren't but there's a third type of
attack that that you wouldn't see in any
of these these metrics and this is where
it gets into you know this work gets
into what can we expect now
the third type of attack would be the
most the most harmful these are attacks
on actual voting systems they wouldn't
show up on any of these kinds of these
kinds of measurements and what what
would happen there is if an attacker
wanted to manipulate the votes they were
manipulated in very small quantities in
key swing states so let's say you know
Hillary edged out Trump by you know
50,000 votes in some key swing state if
an attacker were on those systems there
are ways that they could flip those
votes as we discussed in our last
episode which a lot of these systems
allow for a lot of a lot more input than
you might imagine and that allows for
potential you know additional tampering
so the mechanics of flipping those votes
is actually not all that sophisticated
however what you get into is a situation
where if someone were to have tampered
with those votes and again you can't
discount that that's happened we just we
don't know at this point it would it
would be caught in the reconciliation of
paper ballots to digital tabulation so
in theory there's a possibility that if
the votes were tampered with you know
that could come out in reconciliation
but you know as of this point we don't
have any indication that that was that
that happened I wanted to get to a
couple other questions here as well you
know is the math behind me a new tool
has it been used can it be used to stop
hackers you know it's a relatively new
tool it's more for public consumption
you know people who work in the security
industry they have all this data they
have access to api's that give them
instant access to the stuff this is more
to help the public understand and I
think it's a great tool I think it's
very useful help the public understand
you know exactly what's going on the
internet on a day-to-day basis and you
know what you'll see is there always
attacks this map is always going to be
lit up you know I mean you can look at
some of these other dates here and I
like playing around with this you know
you can find these other dates where you
know you're just seeing tons and tons of
a ton of time to traffic like you know
in this in this case this was back in
December you know bosnia was getting
just hammered with these deed these ddos
attacks and there are lots of reasons
for that you know maybe it's a popular
web site or the government or whatever
you know in terms of stopping hackers
with it gives network providers better
visibility into what's going on and that
does help you know stop some these
attacks but in turn you know for our
purposes these are this is just kind of
a useful tool to see what's going on in
the Internet the second question is the
next question is were there any DDoS
attacks or internet blackouts on
Election Day well there were lots of
reports of mechanical malfunctions and
this was kinda to be expected we've done
some reporting on this you know the
voting machines themselves had basically
the equivalent of you know the effect of
a DDoS attack which is you know a number
of voting machines went down in some
pretty key places North Carolina was one
those weren't the result of DDoS attacks
as far as we know as far as we know this
was just an old technology that you know
just kind of that fails sometimes and it
fails it really inopportune times when
you're pumping the most data through it
that it's ever seen election night in
terms of DDoS attacks they're always
happening so you know that we don't have
any information that there were major
coordinated DDoS attacks against you
know any entities that would be relevant
to election and this question actually
opens up you know a subject that that
we've looked at a lot which I find very
interesting is that you know if Russia
wanted to mess with the election which
would basically be a declaration of war
that's that's how the US would have
viewed it you know they could have
knocked out any range of websites they
wanted and they could have even told
those websites before hand we are going
to knock you out election night now
there's this there's this contradiction
here where if you know an attack is
coming why can't you stop it especially
something like a denial of service
attack which is basically a bunch of
computers just pounding the server over
and over and over again you know trying
to take it down turns out it's very very
hard to distinguish legitimate from
malicious traffic even if you know an
attack is coming you know and you can
prevent an attack one hundred percent at
a time by shutting off the internet or
shutting down your website but obviously
that's not that's not a realistic
solution so we are in this position
where denial of service attacks even
though they're noisy and allowed they're
the most obnoxious type of attack you
can see on the internet and the most
predictable you know when they're coming
you can see them coming there also some
of the hardest to stop because if you're
running an internet service you don't
just shut off the internet you know at
midstream next question we've got is a
lot of people are saying voting machines
aren't hooked to the internet
can hack still happen how another very
good question so when you went to vote
as I'm sure many of you did you know
what you would see is you're not you're
not voting on a machine is connected to
anything these are standalone kind of
pop-up kiosks you know and if they're a
computer it's just a memory card you
know the memory card you pull out the
memory card and that's that's how the
votes are tallied if it's electronic you
know vote machine but there are still
ways that these things can be hacked I
think there's been in general a public
misperception about what's likely as to
be hacked on Election Day voting
machines are kind of eminent Lee
hackable these things are old they're
like very basic processors they're just
very hackable they're just not very well
designed machine so if you can get a
connection to one of these things and
researchers have demonstrated this over
and over you know you can hack these
things really really easily but the way
that these things would happen are more
at the tabulator side which are
computers that are connected to some
types of internets internet connections
so that they can transmit and calculate
the results so that's where if a tax
were to happen they would happen in that
area or in the transmission stage of
states reporting counties reporting
numbers to the states the you know the
next question is you know can hack still
happen and how well this is a you know
this gets to this idea of you know now
the election has happened we have our
president-elect some people are really
happy about it some people or not you
know art should we expect to see any
additional cyber fallout from this and
the answer is maybe if we talked about
before you know if there is any gap in
the reconciliation of paper ballots to
electronic tabulation that's going to be
a monster problem we're not expecting we
don't have any evidence that that's the
case but it's a possibility at this
point it's worth raising and it's worth
kind of keeping in the back your mind as
you watch some of these finalized
results come in but also there's a
really interesting thing that happened
six hours after Trump was named the
president-elect I'm going to bring up
another screen here that I think you all
might find interesting so this is a
report that came out today from a cyber
security firm called vleck City
now what vleck city is found which I
find to be fascinated remember we just
talked about how the denial of service
attacks on election I basically stopped
you know what we see here from vleck
city is six hours after Trump was named
president elect the same group that hit
the Democratic Party the same group that
hit you know Hillary Clinton's campaign
managers email this Russian group that
cyber security researchers know very
well they reactivated they basically
went silent after they were outed for
hacking the Democratic Party six hours
after Trump is named president-elect
they're back at it with this massive you
know spearfishing campaign against
American not you know non-government
organizations think tanks political
entities in Washington you know that
have a lot of people from the government
on staff that that talk to the
government a lot that have a lot of
influence in Washington and what this
firm other cyber security firm found was
these guys reactivated and they went on
this basically this hacking kind of
bombing spree you know attacking these
organizations with emails such as this
the shocking truth about election
rigging in the United States some of
these emails some of these emails
purported to come from a allegedly
hacked Harvard University email server
they purported to come from the Clinton
Foundation kind of offering an alleged
post-mortem on the attack very well
designed to tax and when the cyber
security researchers looked into it they
found it was basically the same attack
infrastructure that hit the DNC so you
know there were a number of examples of
this this one is again the shocking
truth about election rigging in the US
there were other examples as well this
one was you know the election outcome
could be revised obviously for people
who were unhappy with the results this
would be an email many people would
click on even though it looks kind of
crazy like efax solution like I'm not
familiar with is why would I click on it
nevertheless if it comes from a trusted
source or a source that you believe to
be trustworthy and it contains you know
an email subject line that you find
compelling you know this was again a
spear phishing campaign a targeted
directed sophisticated attack against
you know organizations that have
political influence or political
employees what's the takeaway from that
it's hard to know but you know the
timing couldn't be an
you know basically what it appears to be
is that whoever was doing this hacking
against the US political political
system kind of stood down for a while
and once the president-elect was named
they kind of reengaged and you know take
from that what you take from that what
you will however what this indicates is
this group is back at it in a serious
way we have another question coming in
can ballot scanners be hacked to read a
selection as another interesting
question because we saw some reports of
this on election night where people
would punch a button for let's say
Hillary and the machine would register
that is Trump a lot of people are
concerned about that as we all should be
however what we heard was that there's
actually a pretty reasonable explanation
for why that happens and you know if you
if you watch the show with any
regularity you'll hear me sound like a
broken record on this voting technology
is really really old you know in
technology terms when we're talking
about you know annual or kind of
biannual refresh cycles election
technology has been there you know since
Bush v gore and you know in 2000-2001
that time frame in the tech world that's
really really old and so what happens is
you know it's it's easier for the
technology to go bad than it is to hack
it so when it comes to optical scanners
and things like touch screens what winds
up happening a lot of times or sometimes
is the the analog sensors can can shift
these are is a piece of hardware they
can shift so when you're pressing one
button it's actually registering as
another so you know you want to you want
to approach some of these reports of
abnormalities with some grain of
skepticism because oftentimes what
happens is the technology gets old and
fails in a way that Miss registers some
of the results you know ballot scanners
in response to this so this viewers
question you know could they be hacked
to read one selection as another sure
these are all software applications that
run on these things so if you can get
access to one of these things you could
manipulate it in a certain way however
the broken record in me wants to say if
you're going to hack an election there
are two places you do it it's tabulator
or it's the reporting mechanisms for
counties to report results to states
that's where you can do things in bulk
there's another question here coming in
you know voting machines seem very old
are there any plans to improve them
subject near and dear to my heart we
just spent several months reporting a
story that ran on business week's cover
you know a month or so ago about the
state of voting technology and why
things go wrong we reported extensively
on a case in Memphis Tennessee where the
voting machine technology was so old
that it was just dropping votes and in
that case it was primarily from black
churches you know people would go vote
by the hundreds and their votes were
just dropping nobody would know that's
the danger of old technology you know in
terms of your the question are there
plans to improve them there's a lot of
desire to improve them these count no
county wants to have ancient technology
that's hard to maintain you know that
has errors that they know about hard to
fix the problem becomes the reason we
have the electronic voting system that
we do is after the bush v gore you know
court case the federal government
basically opened up four billion dollars
in funding for states and counties to
buy new systems we haven't seen another
one of those you know maybe after this
election the government will will
reconsider that but it's kind of
doubtful basically you're not going to
see a refresh of this this electronic
voting technology and states or counties
without the federal government stepping
in and saying here are several more
billion dollars to you know to refresh
your systems the there are some
interesting there are some interesting
approaches being tried Los Angeles
County is one of them where they're
trying to build their own system from
scratch they're saying we want to open
source the technology one we only use
the best of what Silicon Valley has
pioneered in terms of software
development hardware development that
you know buying hardware from China and
then putting your own applications on
top of it and you know they're using
that federal money they're saying we're
not going to buy any of these old
systems we're going to build our own and
use the federal money to do that it's a
very nascent experiment but it's a very
exciting one because if Los Angeles
could build a functioning system based
on open source technology that could be
iterated on and improved by members of
the public and members of the
cybersecurity community you know and
could be replicated you know throughout
the country so we wouldn't be beholden
to this old hackable vulnerable system
and you know that's really kind of the
hope of a lot of folks
look at this space is that you know if
you can open source if you can move to
more a more modern model of Technology
you know you look at this stuff and you
wouldn't even recognize it if you've
covered Silicon Valley or you follow you
know follow the technological revolution
we've had the semiconductor revolution
and the Google revolution things like
that you wouldn't even recognize the
stuff that you're voting on I mean it is
so kind of archaic in many ways that
there are efforts to push us forward but
those are still in the nascent phase so
you know with that I want to wrap this
up here you know by really by really
saying you know while we didn't see kind
of the Hat the big hack the hack that
wasn't on election night there are a lot
of interesting kind of sub stories to
follow here you know as we move forward
with you know with with Trump's plans to
take the White House and you know and as
these ballots are finalized my big
messages story's not over yet you know
there are still things that you know
that need to be resolved and reconciled
and it will be very interesting for
members of the public to watch this
group that hacked the DNC where they go
next and what they do with the
information that they hack will be very
revealing in terms of how this election
was tampered with allegedly by foreign
power and what that means for us as a
country what we do about that going
forward we've kind of seen an
unprecedented event here and not just
because of the election but what
happened before the election and how
hackers use is a part of it so with that
I want to thank everybody for for
viewing and we're going to be doing this
every week one o'clock eastern so please
you know join us join us next time and
if you miss any of the show and you want
to want to check it out it will be
archived you know on our Facebook and
YouTube pages so thanks for watching a
digital offense and we'll see you next
week